la sphère de breuil les députés rpr
demande la réouverture du dossier
la relance de l'actionnariat 4 millions
de travailleurs déjà concernés mais pas
toujours convaincu cinéma5 oscars à
hollywood pour kramer contre kramer
voilà monsieur bonsoir monsieur carter
sera-t-il au chantage des étudiants
islamiques l'amérique
interviendra-t-elle militairement en
iran que vont faire les européens quelle
sera la réaction des soviétiques
j'arrête là cette énumération qui montre
bien que plus le temps passe plus on
oublie les 50 hommes et femmes gardé en
otage dans leur ambassade depuis le mois
de novembre dernier
et pourtant c'est bien de leur sort dont
il s'agit avant tout il est bon de le
rappeler de temps en temps et ce soir
nous le rappelons avec la présence qui
explique un petit peu notre retard pour
démarrer ce journal la présence à mes
côtés des parents d'un des otages
un marine le sergent terme ning chez
madame vous êtes venus tous les deux à
paris pour demander un visa aux
autorités iraniennes afin d'aller voir
votre fils pourquoi avez vous pris cette
décision
madame
oui bien nous voulions essayer de
comprendre pourquoi les iraniens riz la
position qu'ils estimaient devoir
prendre et prendre notre ambassade et
notre sentiment est qu'il doit y avoir
tapé un but une message qu'ils aient de
transmettre et peuple américain vous
ayons essayé de comprendre gaz iranien
bien sûr nous aimerions voir notre fils
est ici possible ainsi que les autres
charges mais le but principal est
d'essayer de comprendre et d'essayer
d'ouvrir des canaux de communication
personnes non d'espionner parler avec
les étudiants et personne ne leur a
parlé en tant qu'être humain et nous
devrions essayer de le faire
madame monsieur vous savez qui hier pour
la première fois une délégation de la
croix-rouge internationale a pu se
rendre auprès des otages et nous avons
justement en ligne ce soir pour parler
avec vous en direct de téhéran l'un de
ses délégués de la croix-rouge le
représentant de la croix-rouge à téhéran
le docteur harold schmidt
monsieur schmitt est ce que vous nous
entendez vous avez vu vous les otages
pendant plus de huit heures hier
monsieur schmitt
oui nous entendons monsieur schmitt oui
très bien très bien
je viens de vous poser cette question
suivante vous avez vu hier pendant plus
de huit heures les otages dans
l'ambassade alors pouvez vous racontez
nous raconter à nous aux téléspectateurs
français mais surtout aux parents d'un
des otages ce qui s'est passé et ce que
vous avez pu entendre comme déclarations
de la part de ces diplomates américains
d'ailleurs exactement tous les végétaux
relevé le family ont également été
autorisées alors justement j'ai compris
tout à l'heure nous avons dans notre
studio monsieur schmitt les parents du
sergent des marines le sergent r manning
est ce que vous avez rencontré le
sergent r manning et vous at il dit
quelque chose at il donné un message
pour ses parents par exemple
allez-y à les ils sont avec nous à laizy
monsieur schmitt
vous pouvez parler leur parler en
français bonjour la traduction et halo 2
6 me soutiennent mais ce thème
la dame qui est au téléphone schmidt
vous pouvez parler en français à madame
ou monsieur herning
il vous écoute et il vous comprennent
puisque nous avons une traduction
simultanée alors allez-y
monsieur schmitt est ce que vous
m'entendez alors oui est-ce que vous
m'entendez a très mal alors je voulais
vous dire que vous vous pouvez parler en
français à monsieur ou hamadan
nine car nous avons un système de
traduction il vous entendre vous pouvez
parler en français et il vous reste vous
posons des questions en anglais ensuite
qui vous seront traduites l'impression
cela dans des conditions psychologiques
je voudrais vous dire que je ne perds
pas espoir que je ne perdrai jamais
espoir est ce que vous voulez monsieur
schmitt je crois que madame r manning
voudrais poser vous poser une question à
propos de son fils madame airs manning
posez votre question à monsieur schmitt
ou arrive au sénat mais notre île
j'ai entendu dire qu'il avait un message
et je pensais que j'aurais la
transmission ce message tout de suite et
ce que j'ai mal compris
si vous voulez me poser des questions
des questions sur votre fils vous pouvez
le faire écouter une temps nous presse
maintenant monsieur schmitt ce que
voudrait savoir madame herning c'est le
contenu du message que lui adressent son
fils et vous pouvez nous le donner en
français puisqu'on est en train de lui
traduire en anglais au fur et à mesure
élu sous les méthodes ainsi que je vois
je vois très bien est ce que madame
schmidt vous madame airs manning est ce
que vous voulez poser une question à
monsieur schmidt lui poser une question
je voudrais demander à monsieur suite ce
qu'il pense de nos possibilités
d'obtention de visas pour les intérêts
se sent un peu de mes compétences ici
mon travail consiste un peu amélioré les
conditions de détention donc je ne peux
pas véritablement vous répondre à cette
question
j'écoute et je pense que nous allons
interrompre ici cette discussion entre
téhéran ici même je voudrais encore posé
simplement une question à madame père
manning en lui demandant si elle a bon
espoir d'obtenir ce visa pour l'iran est
ce que l'ambassade iranienne de paris
vous a laissé un espoir madame est
revenue et bien nous avons l'intention
d'y retourner demain matin et à ce stade
nous ne savons rien du tout pas encore
nous avons essayé d'obtenir un visa nous
allons continuer nos efforts parce que
comme j'ai dit nous devrions avoir
l'occasion de rencontrer d'essayer de
comprendre les étudiants et les iraniens
et ceci en tant qu'être humain chez
madame je vous remercie beaucoup de
votre visite nous avons eu quelques
problèmes pour entrer en ligne avec
téhéran mais on ne réussit pas à chaque
fois mais je pense que cet échange entre
le docteur schmid qui a vu lui même les
otages hier et les parents étaient tout
de même assez émouvant et c'était notre
devoir nous un formateur de vous le
présenter dès ce soir l'information en
france si vous le voulez bien maintenant
c'est au bazooka que ce matin de bonne
heure à paris un groupe de terroristes a
tiré sur le ministère des transports et
autres locaux parisiens dépendant de ce
ministère il n'y a pas eu de victimes
que des dégâts matériels
mais ces attentats interviennent après
ceux de toulouges du ministère de la
coopération et sont une nouvelle fois
revendiqué par le groupe action directe
jean jacques dufour il est environ 6h ce
matin quand selon les premiers rapports
de la police trois hommes circulant à
bord d'une voiture blanche qui re lance
roquettes ou au fusil lance grenades sur
les bureaux du directeur de la sécurité
routière monsieur christian gérondeau
dans une déflagration qui nous a
réveillés nous as fait dans notre avis
je me suis levée le temps de sortir
chambres de ses sorties pour commencer
j'ai cru que c'était une minute qui
sautaient et je suis sorti je n'ai rien
eu de spécial si vous voulez sinon que
des débris de verre vers la bande par
heure j'ai pensé que c'était la banque
était attaquée
je me suis approché j'ai vu
effectivement que sait-on 4e qui avait
été attaqué immédiatement après ce sont
les locaux mêmes du ministère distant de
quelques centaines de mètres qui sont
touchés et plus exactement ce petit
bâtiment où se trouve le cabinet du
ministre monsieur joël le theule il est
probable que les auteurs de ces deux
attentats qui n'ont heureusement pas
fait de victimes ont été aussi ceux du
troisième commis quelques secondes
auparavant contre la salle abritant les
ordinateurs qui servent au ministère à
établir des prévisions de trafic pour
guider les automobilistes rue raymond
losserand une action spectaculaire
revendiqué au nom de l'organisation
action directe par un inconnu qui a
téléphoné à l' agence france-presse
disant en substance nous revendiquons la
libération immédiate de nos camarades
emprisonnés
ce matin le huitième le 14e le 16e
demain qui sait
la sphère de breuil a été aujourd'hui le
principal sujet de conversation dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée nationale et ce
soir si l'on veut faire le point il faut
dire d'abord que le parti communiste et
le parti socialiste à peu près pour les
mêmes motifs d'ailleurs demande la
comparution de monsieur poniatowski
devant la haute cour de justice ces
motifs et en les suivant la violation du
secret de l'instruction non assistance à
personne en danger de mort et
soustraction de pièces du dossier dont
monsieur poniatowski aurais-tu
connaissances en qualité de ministre de
l'intérieur ça c'est la thèse des
socialistes et des communistes cette
requête sera examinée demain par le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale
à cela il faut ajouter une décision à
laquelle on s'attendait moins celle du
groupe rpr qui demandent une réouverture
de l'enquêté pour les raisons qui
expliquent à daniel brême monsieur
l'abbé du aureilhan du le vol qui tout
de suite nous n'avons qu'une envie de
nous associer nous aligner sur des
positions prises par les représentants
du groupe communiste et du groupe social
la justice est saisie de ce dossier elle
va peut-être décider d'un complément
d'information ne le savons pas nous
croyons que la voie judiciaire est déjà
une voix importante mais ici elle se
révéler insuffisante
c'est à dire par exemple si l'intéressé
michel py 9 qui se refusait à se prêter
peut-être en excipant de son ancienne
qualité de vie à l'intérieur à certaines
enquêtes ne répondait pas certaines
questions
alors je dirais que presque de lui même
il rendrait nécessaire la saisine de la
haute cour si on peut l'estimer par
exemple que le ministre d'intérieur ne
veux pas répondre devant une juridiction
banal en tout cas nous ne pensons pas
que cette affaire puisse se terminer sur
un rideau qui se baissent
dans la nuit sans que la lumière soit
faite alors cette décision du rpr comme
on pouvait s'y attendre provoquer une
réaction de l'autre groupe de la
majorité l'udf par la voix de monsieur
chinaud le président du groupe à
nationale de l'assemblée nationale qui
dénonce l'attitude du rpr et estime
qu'après l'assassinât de monsieur debré
c'est l'assassinât politique cette fois
ci de monsieur poniatowski que l'on
ferait pas je suis profondément choquée
de voir trois présidents de groupe de
l'assemblée nationale se livraient les
commentaires à des assertions depuis
quelques jours le dernier aujourd'hui et
concours au tchad voir des présidents
gros que l'assemblée nationale demandé à
la justice de ré ouvrir un dossier je
considère ces prises de position comme
particulièrement grave tout simplement
parce qu'elle viole un aspect
fondamental des démocraties des sociétés
de liberté et des institutions
françaises qui sont la séparation des
pouvoirs
ph le parlement n'a pas à intervenir
dans une affaire qui est en ce moment
même dans les mains de la justice qui
vient de franchir un stade qui en
franchir à d'autres lorsque l'on
voudrait bien savoir noël copains dans
toute cette affaire quelles sont les
pensées et les arrière pensées car ils
n'en manquent sûrement pas de tous les
acteurs de cette affaire
mieux que de les penser sont
théoriquement claire et les mêmes pour
tous que toute la lumière soit faite et
que la justice poursuive ou reprenne son
cours
c'est la pensée de ceux qui attaquent
directement ou indirectement monsieur
poniatowski et c'est aussi la pensée de
ceux qui le défendent
reportez-vous aux récentes déclarations
de monsieur jean lecanuet les arrière
pensées bien elles sont à vrai dire
presque aussi apparent presqu'aussi
transparente
le parti communiste lui entend donner à
cette affaire toute sa dimension
politique il entend lui donner aussi le
plus de retentissement possible après
avoir été attaquées lui-même toutes ces
dernières semaines
il profite de l'occasion qui lui est
offerte pour développer une vigoureuse
contre offensive le parti socialiste lui
était un peu plus hésitant et ils
s'interrogeaient sur l'opportunité d'une
démarche qui aurait été trop
spectaculaire le rpr lui apprit vous
l'avez vu une attitude qui est un peu
une étude de simples menaces et
le rpr on se demande si comme dans
d'autres cas sur d'autres problèmes
politiques il n'est pas en train de
jouer a retenu moi ou je fais un malheur
de se demander lui-même
jusqu'où il peut aller trop loin mais ce
qui est vrai en tout cas c'est que
beaucoup de membres du rpr ne sont pas
mécontents de prendre une revanche même
si c'est momentané sur monsieur
poniatowski ils n'ont pas oublié un
certain nombre de petites phrases et en
particulier cette réflexion sur les
copains et les coquins que michel
poniatowski avait utilisé dans d'autres
hr ou bien est-ce que vous n'allez tout
de même pas l'impression d'alco pas que
dans toute cette affaire on est un petit
peu loin des vrais problèmes politiques
du moment et sans doute mais je crois
qu'il faut quand même faire ses deux
constatations qui sont à vrai dire de
constatation d'évidence la première
concerne l'avenir
nous sommes à un an seulement des
élections présidentielles et il y a eu
récemment la faire marcher il ya
maintenant cette affaire de breuil qui
est transformé en affaire poniatowski
devra peut être encore d'ici un an
d'autres affaires la deuxième
constatation d'évidence concerne le
passé cette affaire de breuil a
maintenant plus de trois ans c'était une
affaire grave il ya eu mort d'homme et
d'un homme qui avait occupé de très
hautes fonctions or les circonstances et
les mobiles et de cet assassinat demeure
encore très mystérieux il est évident
que ce n'est connu plutôt à la vérité
sur cette affaire
on ne verrait pas aujourd'hui se
développer des manoeuvres à la fois
politique et judiciaire
en cela commente ou plutôt la vérité
sera connue meilleur ce sera pour la
démocratie
un jour elle simplement ajouté avant de
la faire de voir une première dépêche
qui est celle qui émane de monsieur
poher le président du sénat qu'il est
clair que la procédure de la haute cour
de justice n'est pas adapté aux
circonstances actuelles à propos de
monsieur poniatowski et puis une
nouvelle politique celle-là c'était
monsieur michel debré qui était ce midi
l'invité de tf1 et qui a déclaré à
propos de sa candidature éventuelle à
l'élection présidentielle je cite pour
ce qui concerne ma réflexion
je penche vers la candidature j'ajoute a
dit monsieur de vrai que j'y suis prêt
et que s'agissant de l'intérêt de la
france je suis tenace journée d'action
interprofessionnelle le 24 avril c'est
ce qu'a annoncé lui-même cet après midi
monsieur georges séguy une action menée
par la seule cgt pour protester contre
la hausse des prix le chômage en général
la politique du gouvernement monsieur
raymond ben non au ticket modérateur la
réponse de la fédération nationale de la
mutualité française qui regroupe près de
22 millions de
des rangs aux décisions de monsieur
barreaux et donc sans équivoque
théoriquement c'est le 1er mai que doit
entrer en vigueur cette nouvelle mesure
qui prévoit que les petits soins des
assurés sociaux devront s'acquitter d'au
moins 5% des frais engagés le but étant
bien sûr de réduire les dépenses de
santé
pour l'instant les discussions sont pas
rompus entre les deux partenaires mais
chacun campe sur ses positions
jean-marc il use voici l'une des huit
mille sociétés mutualistes françaises
elle gère les cotisations de quelque
soixante dix mille adhérents commerçants
ou artisans parisiens désireux de se
voir rembourser ce que ne leur reverse
pas la sécurité sociale au titre du
décret portant application du ticket
modérateur dit d'ordre public
il leur sera bientôt demander pour les
petits soins seulement de s'acquitter de
5 pour cent des très engagé une
perspective plutôt mal accueilli
monsieur retraité depuis le mode de
100kgs en coupe petite retraite il se
lève 1 million 600 mille francs siens ne
trouve que si on nous prend encore de
l'argent son côté donc facturé m'excuser
on se rembourse intégralement son plan
pour cent supplémentaire et ça profitera
par les assurances sociales pour une
bonne raison c'est que les assurances
sociales n'ont rien à voir là dedans et
ma foi je dois pouvoir le gouvernement
vient s'occuper salle pourquoi le
gouvernement vient il légiférer en
matière de cotisation volontaire il
s'agit d'argent privé
c'était là aussi le principal argument
avancé samedi en assemblée générale par
les membres de la fédération nationale
de la mutualité française
elle regroupe 12 millions d'adhérents
soit 23 millions de bénéficiaires et
refusent d'appliquer une mesure qu'elle
qualifie de technocratique vous le
demande en rien aux pouvoirs publics
demande non seulement la liberté de
pouvoir utiliser comme nous l'entendons
une cotisation volontaire pour nous
protéger contre la maladie et contre les
risques de l'existence sécher droit la
liberté d'utiliser les fonds privés que
nous demandons tout simplement
mais nous ne demandons pas d'argent ceci
dit nous sommes évidemment prêts à toute
discussion et à participer à l'effort
pour arriver à la maîtrise des dépenses
de santé
mais il ya un point sur lequel nous
pouvons absolument pas transiger c'est
celui de la défense des libertés
mutualiste l'effort que nous demandons
aux cotisants minimes
souligne-t-on au ministère de la santé
saint francs seront à leur charge pour
100 francs de soins il faut bien
comprendre que seuls les petits soins
sont concernés les nouvelles mesures ne
changeront rien en cas d'hospitalisation
ou de longue maladie
les assurés bénéficieront toujours des
100 % dans les cas graves
il ne s'agit que d'une mesure de
sensibilisation destinée à préserver
l'avenir de notre système de prestations
d'abord il faut bien rappeler je crois
la portée de la mesure
c'est tout simplement un feu clignotant
qui est là pour éviter que l'on ne fasse
pas attention lorsqu'on dépense en
oubliant que c'est la sécurité sociale
qui paye l'essentiel c'est tout s'agit
pas d'une vexations contre qui que ce
soit et en appelle à la responsabilité
alors je dis clairement aujourd'hui
c'est un appel que nous lançons au monde
mutualiste pour qu'ils comprennent la
nécessité de participer lui aussi à la
maîtrise des dépenses de santé pour
éviter qu'un jour nous soyons obligés de
remettre en cause la sécurité sociale à
laquelle pourtant nous sommes tous
attachés et le monde mutualiste en
premier lieu alors je ne peux pas croire
que cet appel à la responsabilité ne
sera pas entendre une première séance de
discussions ont eu lieu hier entre
fédération mutualiste et gouvernement
elle n'a pas abouti mais les ponts ne
sont pas coupés
il serait difficile aux mutualistes de
se soustraire longtemps au nouveau
décret il serait peu populaire pour le
gouvernement de retirer son agrément à
8000 mutuelle pour l'instant les
positions restent à trancher
mais de part et d'autre on reste
persuadé que l'on est condamné à
s'entendre la compagnie américaine bras
nifff a décidé de suspendre ses vols sur
concorde motif les sens plutôt le
kérosène pour ce qui concerne les avions
coûte maintenant trop cher réussite
technique échec commercial puis pression
aussi les américains c'est donc la
constatation qu'il faut faire à propos
du concorde puisque dans le même temps à
paris le ministre des transports
français annonce que les deux derniers
nés huit concorde fabriqué en france
vont être vendus pour le franc
symbolique à air france
les athlètes américains seront toujours
les bienvenues à moscou s'est contenté
de déclarer aujourd'hui à moscou le vice
président du comité olympique soviétique
ces propos ont été repris aujourd'hui à
paris par l'ambassadeur du récent du rss
en france monsieur
monaco qu'à propos de l'afghanistan a
lui aussi répété la position officielle
de son pays à savoir que les soviétiques
sans oignon le jour où l'agression
extérieure aura cessé après monsieur
sadate c'est monsieur begin le premier
ministre israélien qui est arrivé
aujourd'hui aux états unis pour discuter
avec le président carter du problème de
l'autonomie du palestinien et de la
palestine
il faudra régler avant le 26 mai selon
les accords contractés à caen début à
cuba aucun candidat à l'exil n'est
toujours partie mais les autorités
continuent de délivrer des sauf-conduits
la situation tout au moins sur le plan
sanitaire apparaît de moins en moins
dramatique vraie mesure où beaucoup de
réfugiés munis de leurs sauf-conduit ont
pu regagner leur domicile
le leader du parti communiste italien
monsieur berling ware est arrivé en
chine voyage important dans le contexte
politique du moment et dont on connaîtra
véritablement l'importance
après les réunions qu'il va avoir avec
les principaux dirigeants de pékin nous
le voyons ici à son arrivée à pékin
justement aujourd'hui
et ne s'agit pas du tiercé mais des
résultats des oscars d'hollywood la nuit
dernière
meilleur film kramer contre kramer
l'histoire d'un enfant est de 2 par an
surtout déchirée entre laurent doute pas
leurs enfants plus exactement
divorcée réacteur numéro 1 de steen
hoffman pour son interprétation
justement dans ce film actrice numéro un
sally field un français a également été
récompensé georges delerue pour sa
musique du film little romance jacques
séguin et france roche ont rencontré les
héros de cette soirée
dustin hoffman et meryl streep les deux
acteurs de kramer contre kramer mais au
fil de l'année meilleure adaptation
cinématographique dustin hoffman
meilleur comédien de l'année et meryl
streep meilleur second rôle mais reste
rip actrice de théâtre venus à la
télévision dans holocauste à l'écran
dans voyage au bout de l'enfer et
manhattan et la femme d'un sculpteur et
mère d'un bébé de quatre mois
robert benton n'est pas très connu en
france il est très inhabituel
il envisage tout le film en termes de
collaboration
peut-être parce qu'il était auteur avant
d'être metteur en scène il nous a permis
d'estimer alward ont collaboré au film
de la conception jusqu'à la fin sa page
dustin était d'ailleurs dans la salle de
montage
nous avons même collaboré au dialogue
évidemment pas pour l'essentiel il a
écrit lui-même toute la structure sa une
et c'est un homme assez inhabituel onu
mellerio il est tranquille si vous le
rencontrez il est pas différent d
nous pas du tout tout petit garçon
accepte on a besoin de moi je ne dis pas
qu'il n'a pas besoin de son père aussi
je crois qu'il a plus besoin de moi je
pense que ce film est une sorte de
croisade social additionnellement les
tribunaux accordent la garde d'un enfant
à la mer sans chercher à savoir si elle
convient à un enfant c'est une sorte de
chauvinisme mal à l'envers
donc je ne prétends pas à défendre de
cause ce que je veux c'est montrer dans
mes rôles ce que je pense de l'avis
exprimé ce que j'aime ou pas si c'est un
acte politique
pourquoi pas pu m'amener au compromis
oui j'étais bien ramener une gars super
choco comme j'avais promis mais tu
toucheras pas la glace tant qu'on n'aura
pas fini ton assiette avec l'avion est
tombé à istres où tu vas revenir ici
mais nettement revient ne fait pas ça on
va tout de suite quand dieu attention
est-ce que tu as compris mais il il
écoute toi arrête de faire le malin vers
le plaisir d'aller ranger sa et de finir
ton dîner attention je te préviens tout
avalé une bouchée de ce rsa va faire
très mal
non je peux l'interdît je te l'interdît
tu comprends à rennes on arrête
si jamais je te vois ont avalé une
bouchée ça va faire mal mal extrêmement
mal joue pas ce petit jeu là avec moi
pour ça immédiatement je vais pas te le
dire deux fois attention je ne le
répèterai pas je ne le répèterai je ne
leur ai pas arrêté dans l'hélico de pied
voilà si vous voulez savoir s'il a
vraiment laissé tomber sa cuillère vous
n'avez qu'à aller voir le film avant de
conclure ce journal une information
importante c'est qu'on a longuement
parlé ici même dans ce journal de la
sphère de la centrale nucléaire de
plogoff entre ceux qui prétendent
qu'elle doit s'installer à plogoff et
les habitants notamment qui ne veulent
pas que cette centrale s'installe
aplogan fait bien ce soir une dépêche
qui vient de me qui vient d'arriver
indique un avis favorable a été émis au
projet d'implantation d'une centrale
électro nucléaire à plogoff n'est pas
encore vraiment officiel c'est ce qu'on
apprend ce soir donc auprès des services
de la préfecture du finistère à quimper
la commission denquête désigné dans le
cadre de la procédure relative au projet
d'implantation a remis aujourd'hui son
rapport au préfet du finistère et elle a
donc exprimé un avis favorable à cette
implantation c'est du moins ce
qu'indique cette dépêche qui vient de
tomber à l'instant le football
maintenant vous allez voir les panneaux
des matches ce soir en 8e de finale de
la coupe de france de football il n'ya
qu'un match qui est remis c'est le match
montpellier-lens à cause du mauvais
temps
tous les autres matchs ont lieu ce soir
et vous aurez bien sûr les résultats
dans notre dernier journal en fin de
programme et puis il y à un tiercé de
munger les pronostics de pierrette brès
sous les yeux j'espère que vous les
avoirs vous aussi sur votre écran le 2
le 15 le 4 le 17 3 6 10 8 et le 10 et
puis il ya aussi une chose très
importante pour terminer c'est la météo
de demain demain sur les régions du nord
et du nord-est temps ensoleillé et assez
chaud en cours de journée tout va bien
ailleurs malgré quelques éclaircies
locales sur les bassins aquitain et
parisien temps frais très nuageux à
couvert avec des pluies et les orages
principalement en montagne dans les
alpes et le massif central
vent d'est modéré à assez fort en
méditerranée
voilà ce soir dernier journal donc
présenté vers 23h par ailleurs claude
demain l'invité d'antenne 2010 et arnaud
de bord grave journaliste américain qui
s'intéressent vous le verrez à bien
d'autres sujets je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 avant de
vous quitter je voudrais quand même
m'excuser un petit peu pour le début de
ce journal un peu mouvementée un peu
retardé mais je pensais qu'il était je
pense et nous pensions qu'il était
intéressant de mettre en relation cette
famille équipe à partir à la recherche
de son fils retenu en otage à téhéran et
de vous les montrer
car ça aussi c'est notre devoir d'un
formateur et nous avons essayé avec les
difficultés que vous avez vue de le
faire le mieux possible comme nous
essayons de faire chaque soir bonsoir
excellente soirée sur antenne 2